well of course it is not Super Bowl
without the food for some that's the
main event all week long we're going to
give you recipes you can make right at
home so we went over to Nellie's
Southern Kitchen inside MGM Grand Chef
Mario showed us five foods for game day
get ready first up creamy colored
artichoke dip
we are talking Super Bowl food I am here
in the kitchen of Nellie's Southern
Kitchen with Chef Mario hello welcome
welcome some delicious recipes but
here's the thing you can make this at
Home Folks so it doesn't have to be you
don't have to have all the accolades and
all the experience as a chef nope you're
gonna make it easy what's number one
what do we got here we have some
softened cream cheese okay we're making
uh collard green dip like a spinach dip
but a little spin-off okay okay
it's healthy absolutely okay so collard
greens we have some blanched collard
greens you just take some fresh collard
greens and boil them in salt and pepper
to Blanche I would say about 15 minutes
or so you just want them to still be
bright green they're still soft okay
okay so to the softened cream cheese oh
cream cheese
spinach absolutely that's the southern
flavor Southern Flair Mayo okay about a
cup of mayo
and we're gonna do a little bit of
chopped garlic oh all right just a tad
bit of cayenne to give it a little more
heat okay
and then with that we're gonna have some
artichokes canned artichokes parmesan
cheese okay nice and cheesy let's get it
nice and cheesy and then we're just
gonna do salt and pepper to taste get in
there real good you just want to make
sure everything's combined she's going
to take this and put it in your favorite
dish
today I'm going to use the cast iron
skillet 15 minutes in order just until
it's golden brown wow wow and here I
thought I could just eat it like this
that looks good and you can you
definitely can eat it cold I just prefer
it warm it's just a nice rich creamy
dish oh yeah
I'm telling you it was really good we've
got the full recipe and all the
instructions on our website 8newsnow.com
just look for game day grub more good
day